soy anti vacunas soy anti vacuna soy
antivacuna soy anti vacunas soy
antivacunas soy antivacunas
[Música]
no estoy vacunada ni me han vacunado
tengo dos hijos ellos tampoco han sido
vacunados no apoyo el uso de vacunas
abrió Mis ojos me siento discriminado
cuando le digo a la gente que soy
antivacunas que no me he vacunado soy
farmacéutica y cuando propusieron la
vacunación contra el covid me sentí
incómoda Pensé en la cantidad de cosas
que hay en las vacunas y lo mucho que no
discutimos en la comunidad médica solo
soy anti vacunas seré muy honesto con
ustedes la prueba rápida que nos tomaron
aquí fue la primera prueba de cómic que
me he hecho
me niegué a tomar una prueba de covid la
vacuna fue impulsada para que
pudieran arreglar las elecciones es mi
opinión personal entonces piensas que
las elecciones fueron arregladas bien al
crecer recibí la mayoría de mis vacunas
pero no quise recibir la vacuna covid la
censura de los medios de comunicación
fue una alerta para mí me hizo despertar
a todo esto nos conocemos mejor a
nosotros mismos que un médico que solo
nos ve unos minutos dijiste que era
farma ceuta Sí dejaste tu trabajo es lo
que parece pero no estoy seguro
cuando se volvió obligatorio el uso de
las vacunas para conservar mi empleo
pero hay un miembro de mi familia que
trabaja para una farmacia me consiguió
un trabajo allí de ese modo no es
obligatorio vacunarse Entonces tu
renunciaste no te hicieron renunciar yo
trabajaba como maestro en una escuela
primaria y me pidieron que renunciara
porque la regla era que tenías que estar
vacunado ya que trabajas con niños Eso
fue tan frustrante para mí porque
trabajar con niños es mi pasión y el
hecho de que me despidieran por una
elección personal es muy Injusto por eso
me apasiona este tema a mí me pidieron
que dejara la escuela de enfermería
empecé Durante un mes y aceptaron mi
extensión religiosa y luego un mes
después dijeron que no importaba suerte
porque voy a la universidad en Oregón Y
al principio decían no no puedes entrar
aquí sin una vacuna Pero pude conseguir
una extensión filosófica y luego querían
hacerme pruebas semanales y les dije no
no voy a hacer eso y después de una
conversación tras otra dijeron está bien
no hay problema
[Risas]
escribí Bryan porque bromeábamos que su
nombre era Brian y no Ryan y entonces yo
hablo de conseguir una extensión
filosófica de la que nunca había oído
hablar
pero no es posible que en ese tiempo no
te hayas hecho una prueba de covid la
mayoría se ha hecho al menos una
llevamos dos años en esto
No puedo creer que me hayan expulsado en
la primera ronda si alguien es el
impostor no soy yo eso es seguro cómo
les ha afectado No vacunarse en sus
relaciones personales con sus amigos y
familias tuve que perderme una boda que
me hacía mucha ilusión de una de mis
amigas en Indiana decidió pedir que los
asistentes estuvieran vacunados porque
sus abuelos estaban allí y eso lo
comprendo pero fue desgarrador no formar
parte de ese día tan especial Sí sí un
lado de mi familia se negó a verme eso
fue algo devastador siento que la gente
vincula ciertos puntos de vista
políticos a mi idea personal de no
vacunarme no soy una extremista de
derecha algo con lo que siento que mucha
gente me asocia no soy simplemente
alguien que no se está vacunando en
realidad tengo inmunidad natural he
entrado en contacto con el virus antes y
múltiples estudios han demostrado que la
inmunidad natural en realidad dura más
en cuanto a la resistencia entrar en
contacto con Coby de nuevo el derecho
sobre nuestro propio cuerpo es lo
opuesto a la tiranía que por lo general
se asocia a eso sí soy libertario
también
inclino hacia los republicanos o
demócratas Solo que debemos tener la
capacidad de decidir lo que queremos sí
Y creo que es aterrador también cuando
el gobierno comienza a decir que están
haciendo esto por tu salud y seguridad
es curioso que de repente el gobierno
empiece a preocuparse por tu salud No
debieron prohibir fumar cigarrillos hace
años entonces existe mucha censura para
poder
encontrar información sobre los efectos
secundarios tengo amigos que tuvieron
efectos secundarios graves pero no
puedes mencionarlo porque una vez que
publicas eso Incluso en el sistema hay
miles de informes por efectos
secundarios y pretenden ocultar la
realidad creo que es Interesante como se
preocupan por nuestra salud pero no
dicen nada sobre nutrición la luz del
sol hace el ejercicio ejercicios salir
de casa y está rodeado de gente que te
quiere todo eso es bueno para la salud
en lugar de eso nos encierran en una
habitación con luz artificial y pintura
no recibimos la luz del Sol y no podemos
hablar con nadie y además ponen una
máscara que no es saludable Nico usa
palabras de moda o solo palabra
aplandemia también inyección me hace
pensar que solo interpreta un personaje
creo que solo habla sin sentido intenta
engañarnos era maestro de primer grado y
muchos de esos niños debido al
confinamiento no habían tenido ninguna
experiencia social en los últimos dos
años y actuar como si eso no fuera
perjudicial para la salud
en San Bernardino a modo personal no
creo que sea asunto de nadie si me he
vacunado No Es Injusto que no pueda ir a
ciertos lugares comer en ciertos lugares
o incluso inscribir a mis hijos en la
escuela porque no han sido vacunados no
es justo y la verdad no es justo para
nadie es mi salud has dicho que tus
hijos no tienen vacunas verdad yo no he
sido afectado eso a la escuela bueno
tienen tres años aún no son muy pequeños
pero yo tampoco me he vacunado y no me
ha afectado en nada cuando me enfermo
puedo estarlo durante dos días y luego
estoy bien Vuelvo a estar sana solo me
enfermo quizás dos veces al año dijiste
que te habías mudado a California Sí
ayer tratando de salir intento mudarme
de California porque te mudaste si hay
tantas reglas sí bien bien en Texas
durante 10 años luego me mudé a Oregón
por la universidad y luego recibía una
oferta de trabajo como pasantía aquí en
California y aunque no me gustan sus
leyes tan estrictas Amigo esto es
California es un sueño poder vivir aquí
cambiemos de vida Quiero ir a Texas
estoy seguro sí tomaré allá
y fue a la universidad de Oregón Y de
alguna manera no se le exigió vacunarse
allí Por qué alguien se mudaría de una
zona más conservadora a una zona liberal
si fuera anti vacunas
levanten la mano si creen que el
impostor sigue dentro de la caja y
quieren continuar el juego
creo que sí puedo preguntar por quién
votaron en las elecciones
Recuerden que soy libertario así Expreso
que no soy republicano Pero es mejor
opción de la que tenemos ahora y los
demás sí yo también soy libertaria y en
realidad creo que
ninguno de los candidatos era bueno y no
me sentía cómoda apoyando a ninguno de
ellos así que no voté cierto yo tampoco
voté no he votado Entonces me sentía muy
incómoda con lo desagradable que se
Estaba volviendo todo todo se veía cada
vez más turbio a medida que se acercaban
las elecciones no sentí que tuviera
suficiente
información sobre ninguno de ellos para
votar con confianza no entiendo la
división es muy marcada pero los efectos
importan y viendo lo que está pasando
ahora Puede que no nos guste ningún
candidato Así que debe ganar uno pero
que sea al que quiere la mayoría es
importante creo yo por Trump de hecho
que en su campaña porque aunque no me
gusta todo lo que dice me gustan sus
políticas y creo que permite a la gente
vivir su vida y no intenta meterse en
tus asuntos espera acabas de decir que
trabajaste en su campaña no tenías que
estar vacunada para ellos Esa fue la
campaña de 2016 no creo que lo exigieran
para la de 2021 pero Yo trabajé en la de
2016 no participe en la campaña de 2020
quería preguntarte más sobre tu postura
porque antes mencionaste que en general
no sientes que sea asunto de nadie Eso
se refiere a la autonomía quería saber
por qué decidiste no vacunarte tú ni
vacunar a tus hijos yo crecí en una
familia muy religiosa podría decirse así
y en mi creencia las vacunas no son una
opción
no creemos que debamos poner veneno en
nuestros cuerpos creemos que debemos
manejar todo de una manera holística
ella hablaba como es mi religión por
razones religiosas acaso se le está
ocurriendo lo que dice ahora libro uno
de Corintios del 2 al 5 dice para que
vuestra fe no esté fundada en la
sabiduría de los hombres sino en el
poder de Dios para mí eso significa que
el hombre no tiene sabiduría pero empuja
y obliga a otros a hacer lo que ellos
quieren y eso es una señal de alerta
para mí uso un verso de la Biblia y para
mí eso fue como bien cree lo que yo creo
también hablando de la Biblia para mí es
como cuando los faraones decidieron
matar bebés y con respecto a las vacunas
no confío en ellas porque intentan hacer
obligatorio algo que podría dañar o
matar a alguien y que solo como
farmacéutico sé lo mucho que las grandes
farmacéuticas ponen dinero en esto eso
estamos en contra de las grandes y luego
de repente ya no ahora todos dicen
Escucha lo que dice pfizer Escucha lo
que dice moderna
ella dijo que trabajaba en la industria
farmacéutica
ella dice que no se interesa tanto en la
política pero creo que en este punto es
una posición política no estar vacunado
levanten la mano si creen que el
impostor sigue dentro de la caja y
quieren continuar el juego
se necesita un voto mayoritario y como
no lo tenemos en su lugar pueden debatir
su sospechas para hacer una nueva
votación
sé que es Nico él es el número uno
porque solo se expresa con palabras de
moda como si se tratara de un personaje
quién puede ser el otro impostor no
sospecho de nadie creo que Ryan también
lo es porque Ryan dijo que esta fue la
primera prueba de covid que ha tomado
confío en ti también confío en ti pero
parece que has investigado demasiado
ninguno de ustedes agotado en las
elecciones correcto es me parece
interesante porque siento que está tan
polarizado que estoy de acuerdo contigo
en eso pero al conocer diferentes
círculos libertarios sé que hay
opiniones diferentes respecto a eso
dijeron que lo son sí siendo honesta No
tengo una visión política fuerte es la
verdad en el punto en el que estamos
ahora es casi una postura no estar
vacunado no puedes decir no se me
proporcionó suficiente información
puedes ir a una farmacia y recibir la
vacuna de forma gratuita es casi una
postura política les guste o no
vacunarse Supongo que la mayoría aquí no
apoyamos los medios de comunicación o no
los vemos Pero hay una narrativa
específica en ellos quiero preguntarles
que medios ven Oye no escuchan sigo el
Daily wire Matt Wash Ben shapiro
kendalls esas son quizás las personas
que más escuchan he tenido problemas
porque ven shapiro ha promovido las
vacunas
pero tengo dudas sobre la postura de Ben
shapiro sigo a Steven crower también al
doctor Robert malón hamppecker hay
diferentes
streamers y medios que impulsan el
mensaje de elegir lo que es bueno para
tu cuerpo
ella trabajó en el campo de la medicina
y es un área donde es obligatorio ser
vacunados ser antivacunas es una postura
política por lo que me pareció fuera de
lugar
me sentí muy desanimada pensé que había
hablado bastante bien sobre mis
creencias así que me sorprendió
si se encienden las luces rojas el
impostor sigue en la caja y perdieron si
se encienden las luces verdes significa
que eliminaron al impostor y ganaron
[Música]
sí
Maddie eres tú no soy yo eres tú
tienes que ser tú creo que
a la cuenta de tres voy a pedir a los
impostores que den un paso al frente
1 2 3
no puede ser
un año nos engañaste
debí saber que era Mason al empezar me
dije bien pensamos igual tenemos una
alianza estaré bien sin duda nos
convenció a todos Bravo bien hecho amigo
Estoy muy comprometido a nivel político
y he tenido conversaciones con la gente
sobre si deben o no vacunarse o el
gobierno debe o no obligarlos he
escuchado muchas opiniones de ambos
lados mi objetivo era ser muy sutil al
respecto y sembrar la duda sobre la
vacuna sin hablar de la plandemias ni
Microchips nadie en ese extremo porque
no creo que nadie aquí llegue a esos
extremos la verdad solo lo dije porque
intentaba conseguir algunos puntos
pensaba que se dijo plan Damián estaré a
salvo sí soy farmacéutico de hecho era
una parte del movimiento inicial para
vacunar fui a los hogares de los
ancianos puse vacunas en sus brazos una
gran parte de mi experiencia en este
sentido es ver el daño que el covid ha
causado en mis compañe de trabajo en el
sector de la salud tengo amigos que
trabajan en urgencia y se lo trágico que
es una de mis amigas perdió a su padre
por culpa del covid hay muchos datos en
medicina que cuestiono como persona de
color y como mujer sé Juan en contra
está la medicina de que personas como yo
seamos tratadas pero la vacuna es algo
que he visto una y otra vez y que no
solo cuestionar los datos me avalan así
que me apego a ellos entiendo por qué
mucha gente está preocupada por hasta
dónde puede llegar el gobierno y qué
significa eso para la gente común donde
ponemos el límite creo que es un tema
muy importante para hablar es lo que
pienso la mayoría de los que son
escépticos de la vacuna reciben
información de ciertos medios o de las
personas que los rodean y que impulsan
esa idea si nosotros como personas que
pensamos que las vacunas son importantes
no interactuamos con ellos se quedan
atrapados en una burbuja bien hecha
genial amigo No puedo creerlo Dame esos
cinco
muy bien Vamos muy bien
me encanta esto siempre estoy listo
[Música]